Warren Buffett says fans are getting
gouged by hotels in Omaha watch out for
the little guy yes he is as he has
wanted to do so he suggested at the
annual Berkshire Hathaway meeting
without this weekend yes worry write a
check now get this Warren Buffett saying
check out Airbnb in Omaha the online uh
you know rental startup right Buffett
tells The Wall Street Journal that he
has grown increasingly concerned about
Obama or excuse me Omaha boy that's
that's a funny one Omaha hotels jacking
up the prices for the Berkshire weekend
some hotels more than double their rates
but hotel operators say that Buffett is
wrong to point the finger at them
they're just being good capitalist like
he is whatever nice capitalizing on
you're fair and balanced you got it you
bastard um well well like I said if Tom
wants to go after Washington that's ok
but supply demand should always dictate
pricing but does this stuff matter air
B&B I'm using uber now there's this does
any of this stuff at the margin matter
you know I think at them I think even at
the margin you're hard-pressed to make
an argument that it does i think the
convenience factor you know if if if tom
you can come into work every day and
feel a little bit more comfortable and
do your job better than maybe it matters
from that perspective yeah i think from
an actual macroeconomic perspective I
think you know we're talking about sort
of marginal landing the sikorsky want to
come into work is just it's tough yeah
well especially when the winds are up
like before yesterday morning in the
rain the rain it was so scary scary buho
Tom